welcome to the show everybody thanks for
watching and before we get going I
wanted to just answer one question
because a lot of people have asked me
they've said you know Matt you you have
your own official podcast now with The
Daily wire you're moving up in the world
does that mean you'll stop doing your
videos in the car now because you know
all the other guys they got the fancy
studio and they've got the desk and
they've got a building and they've got
electricity and they've got you know
special effects and all that stuff but
here you are screaming into a webcam in
your car like the disappointing
stepchild of The Daily wire will you
stop doing that now and I'm the answer
is no as you could clearly see I'm in my
car right now I won't stop doing them
I'm in my car why do I do them in my car
that's the other big question and to be
honest with you it's because I live in
my car I'm a I'm a nomad I just wander
the earth in my car doing Facebook
videos and the daily wire pays me in
bottles of whiskey and cans of beans and
so that's why I'm in my car you can stop
asking now because honestly I feel a
little judged to be honest all right
let's talk about privilege I think
that's a good there's a good segue here
I'm a white Christian heterosexual
cisgendered human male which means that
I've got a ton of privilege I mean I've
got privilege tacked to the hub a
privilege stack on top of privilege even
though I'm doing videos in my car I
still have I don't have as much
privilege as say Michael Knowles but I
have a lot of privilege so I know a
little bit I know a little bit about it
I have a you know first-hand experience
with privilege but there's one
particular aspect of that privilege that
the left is starting to focus on more
now and that is Christian we know about
white male privilege we know about
heterosexual privilege but let's talk
about Christian privilege George
Washington University is hosting a
training session this week I believe on
Thursday so just a few days after Easter
they figured this is a good day for this
training session they're doing a
training session on Christian privilege
and I want to read just a little bit
about this training session the
Christian Post the privilege post I
should say had an article about it
so a description of the training session
asks how do Christians in the USA
experience life in an easier way than
non-christians even with the separation
of church and state are there places
where Christians have built-in
advantages over non-christians I haven't
been to the training session yet but I'm
gonna bet that the answer to that
question is yes how do we how do we have
it easier because this is what this is
what the left's all about now these days
is it's about kind of keeping score and
keeping track and figuring out who has
it easier than than who so we're
figuring out who has more of a right to
complain and so there's this constant
competition I talk about sometimes the
the left has a victim hierarchy or a
victim pyramid if you will and there's
this constant jockeying for position
among the different groups and
demographics on the left wanting to be
at the top of the pier wanting to be the
most victimized victims of all because
that's you know that's power on the left
that's currency but if you're a
Christian and you're not familiar with
how things work on the left and you hear
this you'll say what are you talking
about what privilege do I have and I
sometimes will ask that question about
myself even about about even about white
male privilege which is the most
privileged privilege of all men and I
think where is that privilege where what
can I do with it I mean can I cash it in
somewhere is there a privilege exchange
or you cash it in for dollar bills is it
like with a with a Visa credit card
points you know where you crew points
and then you can cash it in for airline
tickets or a discount on a hotel or
something how does it work well
fortunately one of my favorite websites
everyday feminism calm and I visit it
every day because it's a
a feminism folks not every week not
annual feminism everyday feminism they
they did an article a couple years a
couple years ago titled don't believe in
Christian privilege these fifteen
examples will leave no doubt so I
thought because I imagine that the
George Washington University these are
probably the things they're going to
talk about so let's go through I didn't
even really look at this before I
started doing the video but let's go
through a few we won't do all fifteen
but here are a few of the examples that
everyday feminism gives to prove that if
you're a Christian you have privilege
alright right off the bat number one you
get time off for your major religious
holidays see this is a fascinating one
to me because everybody gets off for
Christian holidays everybody gets off
for Christmas for Easter and I would
think that if you get to take off for
somebody else's religious holiday then
that's privileged isn't it I mean that's
appropriation your - isn't that what
appropriation is everybody's
appropriating Christmas you're taking
off you're taking a Christmas vacation
or you're taking a winter vacation which
coincidentally happens right around
Christmas so aren't you the one with
privilege if you get to enjoy the
benefits of my religion and you're not
even a part of it
I would think that's how it works if
somebody came to me if the daily wire
came to me and said Matt we want to give
you a month off paid vacation because
it's Ramadan and I doubt they would ever
say that but if they did I would say wow
thank you I'm not Muslim but I will take
the time off I'll take the vacation if
you're gonna give it to me great and so
now that's when I would be privileged I
get to enjoy this time off even though
I'm not Muslim so that doesn't make any
sense to me what are some other examples
you can wear symbols of your religion
without being stereotyped as dangerous I
guess but everybody in America can
we're symbols of their religion so I
don't think that's anything special
politicians who create and uphold laws
are likely to share your faith well
except for the whole other major
political party the Democrat Party which
famously booed God at their convention
and kicked God off their platform with
the the Democrat Party one of their
great projects is the destruction and
suppression of Christianity and
Christian morals in American society
so yeah except for them except for the
most anti the most anti-christian
political party in American history
except for those guys yeah the ones that
were in charge for the last eight years
yeah except for them I guess that's
totally correct
politicians who share your faith can
base decisions on their religion I guess
just like secular politicians can base
their decisions on their secularism
atheist politicians on their atheism
that's the thing as you can everybody
makes decisions based on their
convictions that's why it's so stupid
when people say oh you're just you're
just saying that or doing that because
that's part of your religion okay yeah
these are my convictions you also have
that's like saying well you're just
doing that because those are your
convictions yes that's what it that's
what it means to be a person with
intellectual integrity what else do we
have here your community can build and
attend a place of worship without being
targeted for violence well of course you
got to tell that to the church down in
Texas where over 20 of them were
slaughtered while they were in church in
fact there have been several church
attacks in this country just over the
last couple of years people of your
faith who commit acts of violence
aren't said to represent your entire
faith yeah well that's but first of all
that's not true
anyone ever does commit violence in the
name of Jesus Christ you can bet that
that will certainly be taken and placed
at the feet of all Christians
okay the anti-christian people in this
country love if they can to blame
violence on Christians and they always
try to but do you know why it's usually
unsuccessful do you know why it does it
usually doesn't work do you know why
Christians usually aren't blamed for
these acts of violence do you know why
because Christians aren't the ones
committing acts of violence in the name
of their religion Christians aren't the
ones committing terror terrorist acts
that's why we don't get blamed for
terrorism as much because we aren't
doing it so if you want to call that
privilege then yeah sure we are a
religion that doesn't have the same
propensity to create terrorists you can
expect your children to have many
teachers who share your faith yes of
course public school is this bastion of
of Christianity we all know that of
course you're not pressured to celebrate
another religions holidays we'll just
leave it there I let me just clarify
that for anyone who maybe feels
pressured to celebrate Christian
holidays you are not pressured we are
not pressuring you in fact
our complaint is goes the other way we
we don't like how Christmas has been
taken and secularized and taken by
secular people and just turned into this
non religious holiday we aren't
pressuring you to celebrate Christmas at
all we are if you're not Christian we're
totally fine if you don't celebrate
Christmas I have never heard any
Christian person complain that there
aren't enough non-christians celebrating
Christmas so you're totally cool not to
celebrate it this is the interesting
thing about privilege because it seems
to me that Christians Christians are the
ones you know who live in a culture that
is basically against them Christians are
the ones
who don't have the right to run their
business as they see fit in this country
Christians can be forced to make a
product or perform a service for
something that they find morally
objectionable only Christians are
targeted for that it doesn't happen to
anybody else it's not happening to
atheists it's not happening to Muslims
very conspicuously even though they have
the same beliefs when it comes to
homosexuality Christian Muslim
businesses aren't being targeted this is
Christian businesses so no that's it's
only Christians being targeted in that
way and then all these other examples of
privilege are just fantasies they're
just they're just delusions but do I
believe that Christians have privilege
in America and the answer to that is yes
absolutely sure we're privileged
American Christians are privileged
because everybody in America is
privileged
we all have privileges in America we are
privileged to live here and that's
that's the problem with privileges that
invariably it's a college-educated upper
middle class brat who's lecturing us
about privilege failing to see that that
that in America we all are privileged
compared to the rest of the world
especially if you're in college
I mean this is how this is how it always
goes it's it's not usually it's not
someone in Ethiopia lecturing Americans
Americans about privilege usually it's
some it's it's a it's a college student
who's never worked a day in their life
and now they're taking a four year
vacation at this college where they're
partying every night they're not even
paying for it and they're the ones
turning around and lecturing us about
privilege and then we have to listen to
the lecture and say okay fine yeah go
back to your dorm room and let me let me
get back to work let me go home to my
kids oh I take care of you no let me go
back to the house that I'm paying for we
all should feel privileged to live in
America as opposed to Zimbabwe or
something like that in fact I don't feel
ashamed of
privilege because our privilege comes
from the fact that we have you know
relatively we are a relatively free and
prosperous country my shame I don't feel
ashamed of that my shame comes from the
fact that we are less free and less less
prosperous and therefore we have less
privilege today than we did in the past
because these are privileges that were
fought for and won and earned by our
ancestors and handed to us and we've
been in the process of squandering them
so don't be ashamed of your privilege
the privilege that was given to you by
our aunt by your ancestors and the
people who found in this country be
ashamed of the fact that you have less
of it now than you should because you
squandered it and it's not just us you
know I also go back to the baby boomers
I mean this has been a process of
squandering our privilege that's been
going on for a couple of generations now
so we all have privilege but if you want
to single out Christians and and use
this term Christian privilege well
that's a problem because across the
world across time across history
Christians are among the least
privileged people even now today
Christians are easily among the least
privileged and most persecuted group in
the world there was a report recently
that revealed that Christian persecution
and genocide is worse now than it's ever
been in history if Christians in
Afghanistan Somalia Sudan Pakistan Libya
Iraq Yemen Iran Egypt many other
countries are regularly imprisoned
tortured beaten raped martyred their
their their churches are destroyed their
houses are burned they have to meet and
worship in secret underground you know
we're back in the catacombs in Rome in
many parts of the world they live their
lives in constant danger just because
they're Christian so tell them about
Christian privilege okay there's about
215 million Christians in the world who
face what is
referred to as extreme persecution so
that's persecution that is violence
oppressive persecution and it's
estimated that around a million
Christians have been slaughtered since
2005
there's no way to know exactly how many
because the countries that do this don't
exactly keep records but we do know and
we can kind of come to estimates based
on the fact that Christianity has been
drastically dramatically reduced in
parts of the world where it's existed
for nearly 2,000 years just look at
Egypt st. mark tradition tells us that
st. mark brought Christianity to Egypt
in the early part of the first century
and now that seed that he's planted and
that's been there and growing for 2,000
years has been almost entirely ripped up
and every month you hear about another
Massacre that's happening in Egypt the
Coptic Christians have been almost
completely driven out of that country so
all across the world believers are being
blown up incinerated shot beheaded and
not just in Muslim countries although
largely in Muslim countries but were the
worst Christian persecutor in the world
is North Korea in North Korea if you're
a Christian though they'll ship you off
to the gulag to the concentration camp
and you're not coming out in China
Christianity is still criminalized so
again tell them about Christian
privilege maybe maybe invite them invite
some of them to your to your seminar on
Christian privilege because they'll be
fascinated to learn about it
it will be news to them I'll tell you
that now there are many examples of this
of this persecution of Christians across
the world I wanted to point to just one
while we're on the subject because I
think this is a particular particularly
powerful and tragic but also quite
common example of persecution they face
this was this was a year to a year or
two ago in Egypt
there were a group of Coptic Christians
they were on buses headed to a monastery
in the desert to pray they were on a
pilgrimage and this is a dangerous thing
to do in Egypt whereas in this country
Christian can get in his car drive the
church on Sunday 10 minutes down the
road and there's not going to be any
Islamic militants patrolling the area
ready to put a bullet in their heads and
make slaves of their children that's the
case in Egypt and yet Christians in this
country still can't be bothered to get
up and go to church even though there's
nothing at all stopping them so they are
privileged in that way in the way that
we all are privileged in America but
these Christians they knew the risks and
and they did it because they they felt
compelled spiritually and the buses were
stopped by these Muslim militants and
they boarded the buses but they did they
didn't just shoot indiscriminately and
kill everybody on the bus instead they
pulled the people out of the bus and
they interrogated them and they asked
them first
are you Christian and then they asked
them or demanded rather that they
renounce Christianity and convert to
Islam so basically these martyrs and all
the ones that died they all were
martyred including the children these
martyrs had to choose martyrdom twice
because they just imagined they've got
the gun to their head and they're asked
the first question are you a Christian
if the some and all this courage to say
yes and they probably imagined that
they'll be killed right there that as
soon as they say yes that's it but then
they're told
okay convert to Islam and now they have
another chance to kind of back away and
save their lives and take the Cowardly
way out and at the some and all that
courage once again and look these people
in the eye holding holding guns to their
heads and say no
and I think it's pretty powerful that in
this permissive age that we live in and
it's permissive culture in a culture
where Christians are in our culture
anyway are terrified of saying no to
anyone about anything they won't say no
to anything I mean this is the age of
tolerance and acceptance and welcoming
and permitting so how powerful is it
that the word that made these Christians
into martyrs was no I think there's a
lesson we could take from that and then
they were killed and left there in the
desert to rot so I don't know if George
Washington University I don't know if
they're gonna cover that story I don't
know if they'll mention that but if
you're trying to create this image of a
privileged Christianity of a
Christianity that has power and wealth
and and a Christian in oppressive
Christianity a Christianity that's out
there oppressing the world if you want
to believe that it requires you to never
look beyond your own borders all these
people in college to pretend to be so
worldly hey let's learn about other
cultures they know nothing about the
world they know nothing about other
cultures because when you go into that
pursuit when you when you pursue
knowledge about the world yet you're
hampered by your bigotries by your
anti-christian bigotry and you have this
narrative that you're trying desperately
to protect this narrative of the of the
privileged Christian of the oppressive
Christian well when you have that there
and that's the blinder and then you go
out and you try to learn about the world
you can't learn anything because
everywhere you turn once you leave the
borders of this country everywhere you
turn you find evidence to the contrary
you find that Christians are being
killed and slaughtered and martyred and
also by the way Christians
are in every nook and cranny and crevice
of this kind of this world helping
people ministering to them feeding the
poor treating the sick it's Christians
doing that it's not atheists okay there
aren't millions of American Atheists
all across the world in all of the in
all of these godforsaken impoverished
dangerous places you know setting up
hospitals and missions and helping
people and feeding them it's not a
theist doing that it's Christians all
across the world but if you want to
believe in the privileged Christian you
also have to ignore that fact as well
all right thanks for watching everybody
and thanks for joining the discussion
I'll talk to you tomorrow